LOW OF 70.
STEVE: MEANWHILE LET’S FIND OUT
WHERE LOUISIANA SENATOR JOHN
KENNEDY IS ON THIS FRIDAY, GOOD
MORNING TO YOU, SENATOR, WHERE
ARE YOU?
>> GOOD MORNING.
I’M BACK IN LOUISIANA RECOVERING
FROM THE LAST HURRICANE.
STEVE: THAT’S RIGHT LAST TIME
YOU WERE WITH US, YOU DIDN’T
HAVE ELECTRICITY IN YOUR NECK OF
THE WOODS, AND YOU HAD CELL
SERVICE THAT WAS A LITTLE SPOTTY
, BUT FOLKS IN THAT AREA
NOW ARE ON THE MEND AND DRYING
OUT AND TRYING TO REBUILD, RIGHT
>> YES.
WE HAD ANOTHER HURRICANE COME
THROUGH, NICHOLAS.
IT WASN’T AS BAD AS IDA.
WE STILL GOT ABOUT 100,000
PEOPLE WITHOUT ELECTRICITY.
AS I’VE SAID BEFORE, EXCEPT FOR
NEW ORLEANS, WHERE THE LEV
IES HELD, THANK THE LORD,
THESE LAST TWO HAVE BEEN WORSE
THAN KATRINA, BUT YOU KNOW,
LOUISIANA IS TOUGH AS A BOOT.
WE’LL RECOVER.
PETE: NO DOUBT.
WELL SENATOR, AS THERE’S A LOT
OF THINGS GOING ON IN OUR NEWS
MEDIA TAKE YOUR PICK,
AFGHANISTAN, BOOKS AND
ACCUSATIONS AND THINGS GOING ON.
WELL AS THAT’S HAPPENING, FOX
NEWS IS BUSY AT WORK STILL
ATTEMPTING COVER WHAT’S
HAPPENING AT OUR SOUTHERN BORDER
, WHICH HAS GOTTEN NO
BETTER IN FACT ITS GOTTEN A LOT
WORSE AND NEW IMAGES CAPTURED BY
OUR DRONE DOWN THERE RECENTLY
SHOW THAT OVER 10,000 ILLEGALS
ARE NOW BASICALLY HUDDLED
UNDERNEATH A BRIDGE IN DEL RIO,
TEXAS.
THESE ARE EXCLUSIVE PHOTOS THAT
WE HAVE SHOWING THIS CRISIS DOWN
THERE, YET, SENATOR, THE FAA,
WHICH IS CHARGED WITH
CONTROLLING THE AIR SPACE, IS
NOW SAYING HU-HUH, NOT SO FAST,
NO MORE DRONES HERE IS WHAT THEY
SAID.
THE BORDER PATROL REQUESTED THE
TEMPORARY FLIGHT RESTRICTION
DUE TO DRONES INTERFERING WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT FLIGHTS ON THE
BORDER, AS WITH ANY TELL TO
RARE IT FLIGHT RESTRICTION,
MEDIA IS ABLE TO CALL THE FAA TO
MAKE REQUESTS TO OPERATE IN THE
AREA.
SO, DUE TO DRONES INTERFERING
WHAT WAS INTERFERING?
WAS IT THE DRONES INTERFERING
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT OR  IS IT
INTERFERING WITH THE COVERAGE OF
HOW THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
WANTS THE BORDER?
STEVE: MESSAGING.
>> WELL IT WAS THE COVERAGE.
LOOK, I REGRET HAVING TO SAY
THIS , BUT WHEN IT COMES TO
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION, YOU JUST
CAN’T TRUST THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
IT BE LIKE TRUSTING HARVEY
WEINSTEIN WITH YOUR DAUGHTER.
WHEN IT COMES TO ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION LIES LIKE THEY
BREATHE.
THEY’RE LIKE TIMESHARE SALESMEN.
THE TRUTH IS THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS AN OPEN
BORDER POLICY.
THE TRUTH IS THAT THIS YEAR
WE’LL HAVE WELL OVER 2 MILLION
PEOPLE COMING INTO OUR COUNTRY,
ALLOWED IN BY THE PRESIDENT, AND
WE DON’T HAVE THE SLIGHTEST IDEA
WHO THEY ARE, AND I BELIEVE THAT
THE REASON THAT THEY’RE LIMITING
DRONE USAGE IS BECAUSE THEY
DON’T WANT THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
TO KNOW, AND I THINK THIS IS
ILLEGAL AND I THINK THEY ARE
ALSO MISS READING THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SUPPORT
LEGAL IMMIGRATION.
THAT’S WHY WE WELCOME ABOUT A
MILLION OF OUR WORLD’S NEIGHBORS
EVERY YEAR TO BECOME AMERICAN
CITIZENS LEGALLY.
THAT’S MORE THAN ANY OTHER
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD, BUT WE DO
NOT SUPPORT ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
WHEN YOU ASK THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT IT, THEY
SAY WELL, YOU’RE NOT FORMATION
BECAUSE YOU’RE RACIST.
VETTING PEOPLE AT THE BORDER IS
NOT RACIST.
IT’S PRUDENT.
EVERY COUNTRY DOES IT AND THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE THE
SOUTHERN BORDER KIND OF
LIKE THEY SEE THE FRONT DOOR OF
THEIR HOUSE.
THEY DON’T LOCK THEIR FRONT DOOR
AT NIGHT BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
KEEP EVERYBODY OUT, THEY HATE
EVERYBODY ON THE OUTSIDE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE LOCK THEIR
FRONT DOOR AT NIGHT BECAUSE THEY
LOVE THE PEOPLE ON THE INSIDE,
AND THEY WANT TO KNOW WHOSE
COMING INTO THEIR HOME, AND
THAT’S WHAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
BELIEVE AND IF YOU ASK THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WHAT THEY BELIEVE
, THEY’LL TELL YOU THE
SAME THING, BUT YOU HAVE TO
WATCH WHAT THEY DO, NOT WHAT
THEY SAY, AND WE NOW HAVE AN
OPEN BORDER POLICY.
THE NUT JOBS ARE IN CHARGE, IN
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
AINSLEY: IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PANDEMIC TOO.
WE HEAR THE PRESIDENT SAY
THERE’S A MANDATE, YOU HAVE TO
GET VACCINATED, MAKING YOU AND
ALL OF YOUR COLLEAGUES GET
VACCINATED.
FEDERAL WORKERS HAVE TO GET
VACCINATED OR  THEY HAVE TO
GET TESTED WEEKLY.
SO IT’S SUCH, IT’S SO
HYPOCRITICAL BECAUSE DOWN AT THE
BORDER ANYONE CAN COME IN AND
THEY DON’T HAVE TO GET
VACCINATED AND WE’RE HEARING
SOMETIMES THEY AREN’T EVEN
TESTED.
>> WELL THEY DON’T HAVE TO GET
VACCINATED, BUT MORE, OR  AS
IMPORTANTLY, AINSLEY, WE
DON’T HAVE THE SLIGHTEST IDEA
WHO THEY ARE.
I’M SURE THAT SOME ARE PEOPLE
WHO WANT TO COME TO AMERICA FOR
A BETTER LIFE.
THAT’S FINE, I’M PROUD OF THAT,
BUT THAT’S WHY WE HAVE A LEGAL
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM, BUT SOME OF
THE PEOPLE COMING IN, WE KNOW,
ARE CRIMINALS.
THEY ARE CHILD PREDATORS, THEY
ARE DRUG DEALERS, THEY’RE
TERRORISTS, AND THE IDEA OF
SAYING ANYBODY WHO WANTS TO COME
IN CAN COME IN IS LUNACY AND THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE DON’T
SUPPORT IT, WHICH IS WHY I THINK
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
PREVENTING THE USAGE OF THE
DRONES.
STEVE: AND ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY THERE’S BEEN SUCH A SURGE IN
DEL RIO IS EIGHT DAYS AGO THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
ANNOUNCED THEY NO LONGER WOULD
DEPORT HAITIANS BACK TO HAITI
AND SO THE HAITIANS WHO WERE
HERE, I THINK THERE WERE 4,000
ON WEDNESDAY, THEY GOT ON THE
PHONE AND CALLED THEIR LOVED
ONES IN HAITI AND SAID COME ON
UP, BECAUSE THE BORDER IS WIDE
OPEN, AND THAT IS WHY THERE’S A
SURGE CLOSE TO 11,000 UNDER THAT
BRIDGE LAST NIGHT.
MEANWHILE, SENATOR, LET’S TALK A
LITTLE BIT.
GO AHEAD.
>> SURE.
NO YOU GO AHEAD.
STEVE: I WAS GOING TO CHANGE
TOPICS.
DID YOU WANT TO SAY ONE MORE
THING ABOUT THAT?
>> WELL I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AREN’T
RACIST ABOUT ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION
THEY JUST AREN’T.
HAVING ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION
POLICY IS NOT RACIST.
EVERY COUNTRY IN THE WORLD DOES
IT AND HAVING A BORDER WALL IS
NOT RACIST.
THAT’S WHY MANY COUNTRIES IN THE
WORLD HAVE A BORDER WALL AND
TRY TO CONTROL IMMIGRATION, BUT
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
TURNED THIS ISSUE OR  TRIED TO
TURN IT INTO A RACIAL ISSUE,
LIKE EVERYTHING ELSE I GUESS,
AND I THINK THEY’RE MISS JUDGING
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
STEVE: ALL RIGHT MEANWHILE I WAS
GOING TO SWITCH OVER TO THE FACT
THAT LATER TODAY, THE FDA
ADVISORY COMMITTEE IS GOING TO
MEET TO FIGURE OUT WHETHER OR
NOT PEOPLE HAVE ALREADY GOTTEN
THE VACCINE SHOULD GET A BOOSTER
SHOT, BECAUSE IT APPARENTLY
HELPS PEOPLE, BUT THEN AT THE
SAME TIME, YOU’VE GOT THE
GOVERNMENT IS BUYING MORE OF
THE MONOCLONAL ANTIBODIES TO
AVOID SHORTAGES BECAUSE THE
CORONAVIRUS IS SURGING.
JEN PSAKI POINTED OUT YESTERDAY,
I THINK, THAT 70% OF ALL THAT
STUFF IS GOING TO SEVEN
DIFFERENT STATES AND YOUR STATE
IS ONE OF THEM WHERE THE DELTA
IS REALLY BIG PROBLEM RIGHT NOW.
>> UH-HUH.
WELL, I THINK THAT CLEARLY,
WE’RE IN THE MIDST OF A SURGE.
I THINK WE HAVE ENOUGH VACCINE
AND ENOUGH MEDICINE TO TREAT
EVERYBODY IN AMERICA, AND TO
HELP OTHER PEOPLE IN THE WORLD,
I BELIEVE THAT.
I THINK THAT THE PRESIDENT’S
VACCINE MANDATE HAS PROBABLY SET
US BACK IN TERMS OF GETTING
PEOPLE VACCINATED.
THE PRESIDENT IS APPARENTLY
DECIDED THAT HE NEEDS TO PROTECT
AMERICANS FROM THEIR DANGEROUS
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
APPARENTLY THE NEW RULE OF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS THAT
, HOW CAN I PUT THIS?
THE TALIBAN GETS BLACKHAWKS AND
THE UNVACCINATED GET FIRED.
NOW THAT’S A HELL OF A RULE.
DON’T MISUNDERSTAND ME.
I SUPPORT THE VACCINE.
I’VE TAKEN THE VACCINE.
I THINK THE VACCINE WORKS.
EVERY ONE OF MY CONSTITUENTS
THAT ASKS ME ABOUT IT, I TELL
THEM THAT.
I TELL THEM THE VACCINE WASN’T
DEVELOPED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
IT WAS DEVELOPED BY THE PRIVATE
SECTOR, THE TECHNOLOGY IS NOT
NEW, THE  MRNA TECHNOLOGY HAS
BEEN STUDIED FOR 10 YEARS, BUT
HAVING SAID THAT, THE PRESIDENT
IS ONE PART OF OUR MADISONIAN
SYSTEM OF OUR
SEPARATION OF POWERS AND THE
FEDERAL SYSTEM AND THE
PRESIDENT DOESN’T JUST GET
TO SAY EVERYBODY HAS TO HAVE
A SHOT.
WHEN WE CONFRONT THESE ISSUES OF
PERSONAL FREEDOM VERSUS PUBLIC
SAFETY, WHICH WE DO ALL THE TIME
, THOSE DECISIONS WERE
MADE BY THE PEOPLE AND THEY’RE
MADE AT THE STATE LEVEL AND AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL THROUGH THE
PEOPLE’S ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES.
AT A MINIMUM, THEY’RE MADE BY
CONGRESS SO I DON’T THINK
CONGRESS REALLY HAS THE SAY HERE
I THINK IT’S UP TO THE PEOPLE
THROUGH THEIR LOCAL
REPRESENTATIVES.
IT’S JUST LIKE WITH LOCKDOWNS.
SOME STATES, LIKE CALIFORNIA,
THEY THINK LOCKDOWNS WORK.
I DON’T.
I THINK WE’VE PROVEN THAT, BUT
IF CALIFORNIA WANTS TO LOCKDOWN,
THEY HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO DO IT
THE PRESIDENT SHOULDN’T MANDATE
IT FOR THEM OR  ANYBODY ELSE NOR
SHOULD HE BE MANDATING THE
VACCINE.
I THINK IT’S GOING TO CAUSE
PEOPLE NOT TO GET THE VACCINE.
WE’RE MAKING SOME PROGRESS IN
TERMS OF CONVINCING PEOPLE TO
TAKE THE JAB AND I THINK THIS IS
GOING TO SET US BACK AND I HATE
TO SAY IT BUT I THINK THERE WAS
A POLITICAL ELEMENT TO THIS TOO.
PETE: SENATOR NOW IT’S GOING TO
CAUSE PEOPLE TO LOSE THEIR JOBS
BECAUSE AS THE EMPLOYEE MANDATE
KICKS IN EMPLOYERS ARE HAVING TO
MAKE REALLY DIFFICULT DECISIONS,
AND WHETHER IT’S IN THE PRIVATE
OR  THE PUBLIC SECTOR, THERE IS
A AURORA OREGON FIRE CHIEF WHOSE
NOW SUING OREGON, HIS NAME IS
JOSH WILLIAMS BEING MANDATED,
HIS EMPLOYEES WHO HAVE NOT
GOTTEN THE SHOT, IF THEY DON’T
GET IT THEY’RE GOING TO BE FIRED
HERE IS WHAT HE SAID ON FOX NEWS
PRIMETIME.
>> I’VE BEEN IN EMERGENCY VERSE
FOR 28 YEARS MAKING DECISIONS
THAT IMPACT PEOPLE’S LIVES EVERY
DAY.
I CAN SURE AS HELL MAKE A
DECISION WHAT I PUT IN MY OWN
BODY.
I’VE MADE THIS DECISION
BASICALLY WHAT A HAS HAPPENED IS
THE STATE OF OREGON ALSO TOLD ME
AS AN EMPLOYER THAT I CAN NOT
EMPLOY A FIREFIGHTER OR  A
VOLUNTEER FIREFIGHTER.
THEY’RE TELLING ME THAT COME
OCTOBER 18 I HAVE TO GET RID OF
THOSE PEOPLE AND I’M NOT GOING
TO DO IT AND I’M WILLING TO LOSE
MY JOB OVER THAT.
PETE: FORGET ABOUT FREEDOM.
YOU’RE FIRED IF YOU DON’T FOLLOW
THE MANDATE.
>> YEAH.
WELL WHAT ALSO DISTURBS ME IS
THAT THE IMPLICIT MESSAGE FROM
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS THAT
THE PEOPLE WHO CHOOSE NOT TO BE
VACCINATED ARE A BUNCH OF
IGNORANT TRUMP VOTERS WHO IF
THEY DON’T GET VACCINATED
DESERVE TO DIE.
THAT’S SORT OF THE IMPLICIT
MESSAGE, AND THAT’S JUST SIMPLY
NOT TRUE.
THE VACCINATION RATE IN MANY OF
OUR INNER CITIES AMONG MANY OF
OUR MINORITIES IN THE COUNTRY,
SOME OF WHOM SUPPORT REPUBLICANS
BUT MANY OF WHOM SUPPORT
DEMOCRATS, THE VACCINATION RATE
IS VERY VERY LOW, SO IF YOU
REALLY BREAK IT DOWN AND LOOK AT
WHOSE NOT VACCINATED, MANY
PEOPLE WHO MAKE $50,000 OR  LESS
ARE NOT VACCINATED.
THEY’RE THE ONES WHO ARE GOING
TO BE HURT BY THE PRESIDENT’S
POLICY.
NOW, WHY AREN’T PEOPLE TAKING
THE VACCINE?
I THINK THERE ARE A MULTITUDE OF
REASONS BUT ONE IS, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, THROUGH BITTER
EXPERIENCE, HAVE LEARNED NOT TO
TRUST THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT THE VACCINE OR
THE SCIENCE.
THEY DON’T TRUST THE MANAGER
ELITE, IN WASHINGTON, AND THAT’S
WHY I TELL FOLKS.
LOOK, THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DID
NOT MAKE THIS VACCINE.
THE PRIVATE SECTOR DID.
PRESIDENT TRUMP PROVIDED THE
MONEY, BUT THIS WAS NOT
DEVELOPED BY SOME YAHOOS OVER AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND
SOCIAL SERVICES.
PETE: OR  THEY’VEVERY HAD COVID
AND BELIEVE THAT NATURAL
IMMUNITY AND THE ANTIBODIES THEY
HAVE ARE AS ROBUST AS THE
VACCINE AS WELL, WHICH
SEEMS TO NOT COUNT.
WHY WON’T THEY COUNT THAT, REAL
QUICK, SENATOR.
>> WELL, WE NEED A VERY HONEST
DISCUSSION LED BY DR. FAUCI IF
HE’S STILL RUNNING THIS THING
ABOUT NATURAL IMMUNITY.
THEY DON’T WANT TO TALK ABOUT IT
BUT WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT IT.
AINSLEY: SENATOR THANK YOU SO